[Applause]
so good to see you virtually i know
it's as good as we're gonna get right
now and i'll take it
now jesse we have um a segment on the
show that's very near
and dear to my heart it's called
cookbook club because i'm an avid
cookbook collector
and i heard you are too yes
that's actually how julie and i bonded
we both are
massive cookbook collectors um i have
shelves and shelves of them and it's
it's always been my dream to have a
cookbook of my own
so this has been really exciting for for
me to actually see this through
and julie is it true that you guys
met at a dinner party you may or may not
have been going to but kind of went to
and then it's true
we did not want to go we both positioned
ourselves by the exit sign
and no one was going to sit by the
celebrities so
i had to take the feet and then you guys
became best friends and collaborators
i know i knew that the dinner party
actually worked it was called the spring
street social society and it was meant
to like
you know encourage people to meet new
people and i was just not in the mood
but then look what happened so they
actually did their job um to my chagrin
i mean it really it's funny those kind
of moments
can change your life there was a party
i didn't want to go to and my best
friend dragged me to it
like i really didn't want to go and i
met
um my kid's father and we ended up
having two children so it's true
sometimes going out even when not in the
mood
can change your life and like what was
the initial conversation
how did you go from guests hesitant
guests
at a dinner party to true best friends
collaborators and making
a baby of your own if you will
i mean well how i feel like julie really
charmed me because she
i was asking her you know what do you do
for a living and she um
you know she's talking about being a
recipe developer and she's uh
you know gone culinary school but then
she said and what do you do and i was
like oh gosh
she's she's never watched modern family
she has no idea that i'm an actor this
is great like
i'm meeting someone with to the purest
of intentions
and she later told me that she was lying
she knew exactly who i was
deception i played it cool
is there anything more wonderful beyond
our children
and food and friendship yes i mean i i
love my i'm a new dad
i love my son i read him i actually read
him my cookbook
because i i realized you can read
anything in a child if you read anything
in a storybook
way like they they're just in trance it
doesn't matter what you read you can
read a west dummy catalog so i read in
my cookbook
one of my daughter's favorite books to
read is a cake cookbook
so i'm with you jesse both of our kids
love cookbooks
to read and i have to say they're going
to have to pry this
out of my hands but what was the
catalyst
for the book i mean i am drooling
over the recipes in this book how did
you guys bring your
culinary loves and like geographical
backgrounds to
create what is in the cookbook
it was um that's exactly what it is i
mean it's you know i love
meeting new people and learning about
the food that they grew up eating
um i you know introduced julie to hatch
green chilies and the stuff that i loved
eating in new mexico and she introduced
me to
sorghum syrup and you know julie puts
butter and everything like she has such
a deep love of butter which i'm
i sort of have like a love hate
relationship with it and i'm learning to
love it even more i mean
that's not true i just i i tell myself
that i shouldn't love butter usually
we love it i know it's true but
i think you guys bringing your
like geographical backgrounds together
is what makes for such compelling
recipes
is this how you guys eat in your life
like
i mean yes right i do
i actually i'm i'm making the the
molasses pork chops tonight for dinner
julie
i'm gonna dive into that recipe tonight
so we cook from this book all the time i
mean
justin and i have recipes that are in
deep rotation
um and a lot of the ones that we
actually go to are the ones that that
julie wrote for the book because they're
they're new to me they're
they still feel really fresh so i mean
they're all look at justin with this
chicken
by the way your husband is just so
lovely
and it's so nice because i do think the
kitchen
you know honestly is like the new
bedroom if you will
it's like the most bonding romantic
beautiful room in the house it's sort of
where we display
our love and enthusiasm and passion for
life
and i have to say this is the cookbook
you
want to eat out of it's just incredible
thank you so much